van Kilwa to tomorrow me different I
booties Oh calm the limo holiday Frau
Divas of skulls some eyes visible dents
tisa do capeta condos passenger pyar SE
j ll ghoul algal allow a calm this is
austin mep zarin now familiar complaints
about corporate tax avoidance
facilitated by individual member states
they debated a new commission plan to
include taxing profits where they're
made and harmonizing the EU tax base
corporations should be required to make
public how much economic substance is
created in which country and there
should be agreement about how and where
corporations are taxed the debate
followed proposals earlier this year for
an information exchange on favorable tax
rulings granted to multinationals after
the lux leaks revelations on such
rulings parliament set up a special
committee to explore fairer and more
transparent tax systems we need action
at European level otherwise they will
just continuously make money in the EU
and find one member state where they
don't have to pay anything it's not just
taxation is a jealously guarded member
state competence however most mep s see
room for tightening rules hoping for
raised revenue and extra jobs